The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: I'm going to
go through a number of cases
with you today.
So we'll have to rely on,
sometimes, on this hand
out, sometimes on the slides.
Let me first tell you
what handout contains.
The first is an example
from Philippe Boudon's book,
Lived-in Architecture.
This is his housing for
steel workers at Pessac,
near Bordeaux, which Boudon
studied after a period of time
and made these
drawings of the changes
that people have made to
the original plan, which
is the top left.
The elevations indicate
a couple of things,
because I'm not going to go into
any detail about this example.
People enclosed the open porch
of Corbusier's to make garages.
They replaced long,
linear windows
by rectangular windows of
a much more oblong nature,
arguing that Corbusier's
windows were not modern enough
and so on and so on.
When Corbusier was asked by
Boudon about these changes,
he said, to be grammatically
as possible, life
is more important than art.
There was no indication that
he expected or made provisions
for changes to take place.
He was central to
modernism, that time
was captured within the
space of the project.
He neither looked forward to
changes that could be made
nor did he look back to
the possibility of history
or memory affecting your work.
So one ism, as I tried
to indicate on Tuesday,
was the notion of
fixed culture, which
operated with the production of
objects which had no reference
backwards of any value.
Corbusier is a classic
example of a man who
denies the 19th century street
forever and then proceeded
to make projects like this
one, in which the steel
workers themselves find
the capacity to change
without the change
being premeditated.
We're going to be looking today
at the issue of looking forward
and what unpredictability means.
I will use the case of MIT
on the second and third page.
You will see the plan of MIT
from 1920, 1916, to 1994, 2004.
I will discuss
[? Maria Zepharado's ?] thesis
and what she found.
Next
Two pages from Rodrigo Perez
de Arce's work, arguing that--
it says, demanding adding
on to existing buildings
is an opportunity
for good change.
AUDIENCE: Who is this?
It's not at the top.
JULIAN BEINART: Isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Rodrigo Perez de Arce.
JULIAN BEINART: Rodrigo
Perez de Arce, A-R-C-E.
He's from Colombia.
Do you know him?
AUDIENCE: No, professor.
JULIAN BEINART: He's
a quiet man, who
draws very beautiful drawings.
His urban-- in the larger
reading list for this class,
you'll find the reference.
It's published in
Architectural Design
and also in a little handbook
by the Architectural Association
in London.
I will show some
examples of his work.
The next two pages are drawings
by Louis Kahn and Alison
and Peter Smithson of the Team
10 group dealing with flows.
The next few pages are plans of
European universities from 1961
onward all the way through to
the Free University of Berlin
in 1963, all slowly dealing
with the architecture of change.
OK.
Reaction after
the end of CIM was
in the hands of a small
group of architects
called Team 10, who put forward
the possibility that time
could be escaped from.
That's my words.
They didn't write it.
Alison and Peter Smithson,
Team 10 primaries,
the doctrine of their
work and theories,
they were interested in
notions of unpredictability,
circumstance, probability.
They were interested in
the notion of the temporary
and the ephemeral
versus the permanent.
Secondly, they were
interested in the flow,
in the idea that movement
systems, particularly
those that create
interaction and connection
were fundamental to their work.
And thirdly, they tried to
argue for social reality, which
involved the
complexity of occasion,
as it occurred in most
situations at the time.
They invented words,
like most architects do.
Socioplastics is
their invention.
Socioplastics use
that word which
embraces what the painters like
Richard Hamilton and Eduardo
Paolozzi were trying to
do in their painting.
It's interesting
how few architects
of the modern movement or
the post-modern movement
have had much association
with painting.
Frank Gehry is,
perhaps, the only one.
Steven Holl, to some extent,
connect the interpretation
of architecture in light to
certain ideas about painting,
whereas the Modernists were
very much in the mood of all
the painting revolutions,
which occurred largely
in Paris and in Europe.
So we have the notion of
change, the notion of flow,
and the notion of socioplastics
as central to Team 10's work.
We will look a little
bit at Team 10's work.
But I haven't got the
time in this class
to deliberate fully on Team
10 and their architecture
and their urbanistic work.
We have to accept that you
cannot predict the future.
There's a book by Paul
Ormerod, an Englishman,
called Why Most Things
Fail, which sets out
that we maintain to achieve
a particular outcome
but the complexity of the
world, even in apparently
simple situations,
appears to be so great
that it's not within our
power to ordain the future.
He gives the example of the
world's 100 largest companies
in the period from 1912 to 1995.
Out of the 100 largest
industrial companies in 1912,
how many have survived in 1995?
Guess.
AUDIENCE: There's
a good book called
The Living Company, written
by Arie de Geus in which they
studied companies over 200
years old to understand what
would make them last over time.
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
48% of the companies
which were in the world's
largest 100 disappeared.
52% survived.
So that means over 80 years, you
have a 50% chance of survival.
It's more than human beings.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN BEINART:
It's pretty good.
He refers to the difference
between risk and uncertainty,
risk being where the options
are within a span of certainty,
such as flipping a coin.
And uncertainty is where the
options are very unclear,
such as a man or a couple
of men from the moon
landing on the Earth, which
some people believe in.
The difference between
risk and uncertainty
isn't easily discussed
in the work of the people
that I'm going to be arguing
for, this notion somehow that--
how much do you
know of this work?
Who knows about the Free
University in Berlin?
One person.
You all are very ignorant,
if I might say so.
We don't teach history properly.
We don't teach urban
history at all.
I have complained about
this for most of my career.
And seeing this is the last
time I have to complain--
[LAUGHTER]
--I'll complain
finally, for the record.
All right.
We'll talk about the Free
University in Berlin project
by shared records.
Let's just list, if we can,
some of the conventional methods
of achieving
flexibility in cities.
Number one, land banking,
you can endow land
with cheap uses, farming,
parking lots, and so on,
on the grounds that, in future
when land becomes more scarce,
they will be able to be reused
without much demolition.
Farming is not an option which
has been used in urbanism very
much if at all.
Farming in New York is on
terraces and high 100-feet
above the ground, or 1,000
feet above the ground.
Secondly, easements--
easements are
rights of way which can be
endowed with limited use,
such as on the
sides of highways.
When we spoke
about Robert Moses,
I spoke about the lack of
his provision of easements
on his freeways.
The cost of providing
the easement
would have allowed the addition
of public transportation
next to these roads at
a cost, which is now
estimated to be a
fraction of what it now
would cost to do them.
So you allow the possibility
of an event taking place
on land which is easily
available and costs very little
initially, but increases
in value as time passes.
The problem with
prediction is that there's
a difference between
the right prediction
and the excessive prediction.
Now, it's between too little
response and too much response.
Prediction costs money
under most circumstances.
You can also do
excessive prediction.
I think I showed you a diagram
of a South African mining
town, a classic case
where the town was
designed so that the central
businesses could expand.
The expansion area around
the center of the city
was so poorly treated, so badly
landscaped, not landscaped
at all.
It was just dirt.
It, in fact, caused the
center business area
not only to grow, but to decline
in size instead of to expand.
Leaving land for expansion
is one of the ideas
that we'll look at a
bit more carefully.
You can leave open
space for consumption,
assuming a coarse
grain in your town.
I will show you the example of
the Seoul the Olympics in 1988,
which built its Olympic Games
on the basis of a fairly
large open space system.
Who knows the 1988
Olympic Games?
Were you there?
AUDIENCE: Not at the
Games, I know the site.
JULIAN BEINART:
You know the site.
Yeah.
It's a classic example of the
cannibalization of easy access
space.
Open space is easy access.
It's cheap-- not cheap
in the public's mind,
but cheap in the
promoter's mind.
And most of the facilities,
including the Olympic Village
by Kyu Sung Woo, who
lives here in Cambridge,
was built on this
available land.
We'll come to
Seoul '88 later on.
I'm just running
through some of these.
There's infrastructure
for flexibility.
When we designed the MIT
Brain and Cognitive Sciences
building, we had to allow
for the C86 railroad
to run through underneath
the building that
made an extraordinary difference
in the kind of building
which you could design
but we calculated that if
the air Rights Committee
owned the air right
over the C86 railroad,
about 22 feet or 15 meters.
I'm not sure which.
I think it's 22 feet.
MIT can build 22 feet above
the plane of the railroad.
We calculated when
working on this that,
if MIT exercised this option and
built on the maximum air rights
that the--
well, they have the air rights.
The degree to which they
can build vertically
will have to be
sanctioned by the city.
But we calculated
that, if MIT wished
to expand its campus
vertically over the air rights,
the development would be
worth billions of dollars
in Cambridge in terms
of square footage.
So imagine the possibility of
a future in which MIT could
build above a railway line.
The fact is that we
only built to the height
that Cambridge allows in
our building, which was
large enough for our program.
But this friction caused
by a movement system.
Corbusier's
proposition of building
under the freeways in Algiers
is not feasible anymore.
The noise and pollution
caused by the automobiles
would make it
virtually impossible
to build under the freeways.
One of the dramatic futures
in the next 50 years
is going to be to how
to capture the space
under elevated freeways
all over the world.
They're elevated to
a considerable height
because you have to be
able to pass through
with a truck, which means
that you have to have ramps
at 1 in 10 or 1 in 5.
Depending on how
steep you are, you
can take a large
amount of space.
So I haven't seen a
proposition in recent times
anywhere in the world
for capturing the space
under a freeway in
a positive sense.
We have one SMR
student project thesis,
which you'll see in
three weeks time,
which tries to do this in
Boston with great difficulty.
But the air rights mean
that the development
above a plane,
which for the moment
is used by a railroad or
freeway, and the development
below that plane even
penetrating into the ground
are options which
utopianists have examined
and wondered about.
So we have to include
them on our list.
Lastly, is the
question of geometry.
And most of the
rest of my talk is
going to deal with people who
have used the idea of geometry
to allow for future change.
OK.
One of the people who argued
for the impact of geometry
is [? Maria Zepharado's ?]
thesis.
Maria was in this class
and became interested
in the idea of change.
She wanted to study a city
and make some speculation
about how urban
transformation took place.
She decided after being
forced to limit her thesis
to take a MIT.
MIT, Shadrach Woods, the
architect of the firm, Josic--
oh, I forget the name
of the French firm,
was an American architect
who developed the word ground
scraper as a model
of MIT and used
as the basis for the design
of the Free University campus
in Berlin.
Maria worked with the
drawings in the MIT archives,
which had never been
looked at before,
and made an assessment
of the number
of geometric configurations
that allowed the campus
to grow in the way that it did.
I haven't got time to go
into this detail, as always.
Why are we so short of time?
Is it because we
try to do too much?
But if you don't do too much,
who says what is enough?
Should one take one
project like this
and spend a semester
studying it in detail?
Would you gain more
from doing that
versus attending a class which
tries to cover everything
in the world?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, you made your choice.
Among our findings,
six stand out,
the existence of an
underlying circulation system.
MIT has a block size
of 65 feet in width
in the central corridor
most of the time.
There are three
kinds of stems used.
Number three, the quality
of the knuckles-- whenever
a building changed directions.
Almost always when
there's an opportunity
to change direction, the
vertical circulation system
of elevators and staircases
are contained in the knuckle.
So she shows that
every time a building
changes direction
it is free of having
to replace the vertical
circulation system.
It means that the
circulation system
becomes more intense as it
is joined to other systems.
The fully equipped
unit section--
from the [INAUDIBLE] system.
The courtyard is future space.
I never realized that MIT
intended the courtyard system
as an opportunity for
building expansion.
Thank god they haven't.
The facades-- where facades
were considered to be permanent,
they were built of
granite or limestone.
Where the facades were
considered to be temporary,
they were built of brick,
yellow brick facade.
So she argues very
systematically with a lot
of data that there was a
kind of DNA in the system not
a very profound DNA, but
a very simple DNA, which
allowed MIT to grow until
2004 on its own land.
Our building, the Brain
and Cognitive Center,
is on the other side
of Vassar Street.
It was the first
time a building--
not the first time, but
one of the first times
the major building was built
outside of the limited campus.
We proposed an aerial connection
from building whatever-it-is
across Vassar Street to a
place on the second floor
of the Brain and
Cognitive Center.
MIT wouldn't build it.
We tried very hard
to get it built.
In fact, the German
engineer [? George Sly ?]
who worked on the
Freedom Tower in New York
is probably the best structural
engineer in the world, designed
the connector.
But MIT didn't.
MIT now faces an
expansion possibility
which is not as simple as
expanding on your own land.
It has to deal with urban
infrastructure of much more
complex nature.
Another use of geometry,
which we mentioned before
is in the Llewelyn-Davies plan
for Milton Keynes in London one
of the Mark 3 New Towns.
You'll remember that
the grid is used.
And the grid is spaced at
1 kilometer by 1 kilometer,
not 1 mile by 1 mile,
so that the consequence
of the generation of volume
within this enclosed grid space
would not be too
large and require
great separated interaction.
Some other ideas--
the whole premise
of Milton Keynes' his plan
he summarized as follows.
"The central aim of
the plan is to arrange
the necessary fixed
elements, transport drainage
water supply in
a new city, so as
to allow the greatest possible
scope for freedom and change.
It has been planned
as far as possible
to allow wide varieties
in patterns of life
and the greatest possible
choice for the future."
There are two things in
the geometry of the--
well, in the application
of the geometry.
Number one is the
idea, as I drew
on the blackboard, of
recognizing the possibility
of a space frame system.
A space frame system
in architecture
is a system which spans distance
and allows you to put points
on the load system at
any point as opposed
to point and beam system,
where you can only
load the system where there is
a column beneath your point.
So it's kind of pointless
system or freedom of pointing,
which allows almost any
kind of change to exist.
The notion of deciding what
the maximum amount that you
can allow before the system
cripples itself is interesting.
You have to use mathematical
prediction systems
like the Poisson distribution.
Who knows what the
Poisson distribution is?
You should know.
If you're going to
design a university
campus or a
schoolroom, how do you
decide on the distribution
of the sizes of classrooms?
You're architects.
You're in advanced
standing at MIT.
You're doing doctorates.
You're doing all kinds
of advanced degrees.
And if I ask you the
simple proposition
that, if you had
to walk out of here
and you were in Burma
somewhere and they decided
to build a new university, how
would you decide on its program
without knowing the
Poisson distribution?
The Department of Mathematics
at Cambridge University,
a new building, is
designed on the basis
of Poisson distribution.
It allocates
probability of sizes
given certain average rates.
I'm not trying to be clever.
I'm just trying
to say that there
are statistical measures
which give one a better
prediction about the future.
One of the best subjects I
ever studied in graduate school
was statistics.
I hated it, but it made me
aware of the fact that you
can generate knowledge
through sampling
systems of great capacity.
I was staggered when
my professor said,
the only reason we
have live matches
is because we know statistically
how many matches fail.
And we can predict the
production of boxes of matches
without any of them
failing or 99% succeeding--
staggering, but a
simple observation.
The Poisson distribution is
one of the features of a--
so the second feature
Milton Keynes,
in trying to predict
the possibility of,
first of all, diversity
and, secondly, of change
is to introduce
zoning systems based
on performance dimensions.
The reason why German
zoning started out
was because of the
industrial city
causing noise and dirt and
fumes and traffic as opposed
to the quiet notions that are
required in a residential area.
If today a high tech
company produces
no noise, no smoke,
no sound, can it not
be adjacent to a
residential building?
Of course, I don't know how this
has worked in Milton Keynes.
If I buy a piece of land and
I make a wonderful garden
next to it, it has value.
If the city decides to
build a factory next to it,
I lose value.
How do you account
for that change?
Do you repay me?
I take you to court
and say I have rights.
They say, you don't have rights
to predict, to confiscate,
the rights of development
and so around you.
It's a fundamental problem.
If you wish to
design for diversity,
you can, of course, write a rule
saying that a factory will not
be within 100 feet.
But performance dimensions
measure sound, noise,
frequency of traffic.
If trucks start working, as they
do in New York, at 5 o'clock
in the morning and
I want to sleep,
what right do I have to stop
the trucks from off-loading
at 5 o'clock in the morning?
These are tough questions.
And flexibility simply runs up
against some of these questions
in a very real sense.
It will be
interesting to check--
I need to talk to
John de Monchaux who
is one of the designers
of Milton Keynes,
about how this has been handled.
Rodrigo Pérez de Arce, who
argues in favor of keeping
existing stock and building
an architecture of addition,
he says, urbanistically,
it has three advantages.
"By being a gradual organized
incorporation of parity
into an existing core,
it implies the use
of a pre-existing structure.
And by doing so, it
extends the likelihood
that it's being useful
for a long time.
Secondly, it allows for a form
of development characterized
by its low cost in both
social and material terms."
I'm not sure that he's right.
Maybe it's true in Colombia, but
the cost of renewing buildings,
such as the buildings
around here,
which have been renewed for
high technology purposes,
is extensive.
It's not automatic that, if you
extend a building, all you do
is put a bedroom, an
addition to a house.
And thirdly, he says
that this process,
"this additive transformation
ensures a sense of continuity
in the construction of
the town and a sense
of place in both historical
and spatial terms."
He goes on and on.
This is the piece from
Architectural Design
if you can't find the
AA, the little book.
Let's look.
And I need you to look
at your transcript.
Let's look at the development
of a systematic campus
plan starting in--
the British were
very intelligent
after they won the
war, the '39, '45 war.
They decided under
the Labor government,
which replaced Churchill--
Churchill was interestingly
successful as a war leader,
but helpless as a peace leader.
Maggie Thatcher was
equally hopeless.
She was a big war success
with the Falkland Islands,
big victory indeed.
Yeah.
Anyway, we start
with the 1961 plan
for the University of Sussex.
This is post-war,
post '45, rebuilding
of educational
institutions in Europe.
And I use this data just to make
an argument about the change.
61 Sussex is a campus plan.
They are separate schools.
They are individual categories,
individual enterprises,
School of Mathematics, School
of Humanities, and so on.
By the University of
Lancaster in 1964,
the tension starts being paid
to the connecting of places.
And the system is one in
which modular space is
connected in a complex network.
Number four, the University of
East Anglia in 1961, the plan
is now a solid
linear configuration
with three small outgrowths.
But the whole
system is very much
based on the linearity of--
number five, the University
of Essex in 1961,
tries to take that linearity
and bend it up and down.
By now, people are
asking questions
of whether interdisciplinary
knowledge systems are not
taking hold, biology and science
or physics and chemistry.
So the breakdown of
conventional disciplines
suggests the kind of grouping of
and even a future in which this
might continue, allowing for
a switch to the next page,
University of Surrey,
where you start
getting some inclination of the
idea of building modular space
of various dimensions.
University of Dublin,
[? John Carver's ?] project
starts trying to articulate
the linearity by having
a central public spine, much
like the main corridor at MIT,
and outgrowths from it
depending on the need
to be close to the
public versus space which
requires research privacy.
We go down to the University
of Loughborough in 1965,
which is a major,
major departure.
Now, a 50 by 50
cube by 15 feet high
is the only element
to be designed
in the university space it will
account for 70% of the campus.
What does this imply?
It implies that we maximize
the possibility of change
every space is endowed
with a service structure.
So that my office can become a
space for a research scientist
who needs specialized
heating, specialized air,
specialized steam,
specialized power.
If I produce all of
this for everybody,
we can change with
maximum flexibility.
Do you understand the idea?
This is the ultimate measure
of flexibility, an item which
has infinite flexibility.
In a competition for the
university, new university
of Bremen, one of
the competitors
had a railway line right
through the middle of the campus
with the train
with a crane on it.
And it kept on moving the parts,
modules, all over the place.
So if my department
grew, some modules
could be added to the top
of our existing department.
If we fired half of the
Department of Architecture,
the modules could be replaced.
If you speed that
up, you can imagine
coming to your office on
Monday and needing an algorithm
to explain where you should be
or where you're going to be.
MIT's central corridor, despite
the changes, has remained.
And it has a low rate of change.
It should have changed
much more than it has,
but it's become embedded
into the system,
so that whilst almost every
other space at MIT has
undergone change, it hasn't.
It has the same old
dull administrative--
instead of building a
cafeteria across the street,
MIT should have jettisoned
its administrative facilities
and used this major
corridor as a place
for real public
exhibitions, for eating,
for people coming together.
It didn't.
It lacked the
intelligence or the--
but so excessive
flexibility is very costly.
One of the reasons you
can't do advanced science
in the old part of
MIT is because is
the infrastructure is too weak.
The sixth floor
of our building--
our building has six floors.
Well, the sixth
floor is for animals.
All of animals are
generally in basement.
One of the future for building
university research facilities
given climate change--
New York University, the animal
laboratories in the basement
all flooded.
All the research was lost.
We put ours up in the
sky for no clear reasons.
We thought the animals would be
better off in there than down
in the basement.
And nobody disagreed.
On top of that floor is a floor
of machines, machines which
look like airplane systems.
Because the building is a
laboratory which has to account
for research which requires
highly specialized vectors
of steam, light, all kinds
of elements which the ceiling
depths of about 18
inches, or 2 feet,
in places is so dense that you
cannot get another pipe through
there.
If MIT would have allowed us to
account for future flexibility,
we would have made the depth
greater than the 18 inches
tube.
It costs money.
We weren't allowed
to plan the building
with any space on the building
called TBA, To Be Added.
It's like packing
an aircraft carrier.
An aircraft carrier probably
can change internally.
But anyway, let's move
on with these diagrams.
We're got a few minutes left.
The Potteries Thinkbelt
in 1966, was Cedric Price,
the British architect's, attempt
to do a couple of things--
to eliminate the
idea of a campus
from having separateness
from the rest of urbanism.
He decided to place
this British university
in an area of suffering economic
decline in Staffordshire.
He argued that this
embedding of the University
into the society's needs
would spontaneously
produce another kind
of university, such
as it would stimulate the
economy, for instance,
through promoting a
landlady industry and so on.
Instead of building
university dormitories,
I showed you a project in New
York by the Ford Foundation,
which attempted to do the same
thing that, instead of building
university dormitories,
create a market
for the supply of housing
by the poor people
around the university.
The last of these plans is
the most famous of them.
It's the Free
University in Berlin.
Shadrach Woods writes
about this plan.
"We have not begun
by trying to give
fixed points within the system.
I know they will have this.
People make the identifiable
features, not the architect.
I do not want to make any
symbols to begin with.
I think that the
use of the building
create centers of activity.
The plan is really an
attempt not to make sense--"
and so on to begin with.
It's interesting
that the implication
is that, if you give an
opportunity for people
to arrange themselves,
they will have the capacity
to do so in a correct
manner or in a manner that
is correct for them.
This is a time when Noam
Chomsky was lecturing
about the innate
ability of a child
to construct a specific
system of interconnection
amongst concepts and
conditions of use and reference
on the basis of scanty
and scattered evidence.
Is there DNA in human
beings which automatically
will be able to create better
space than a specialist guiding
them?
Or what combination of the two?
Classical anarchism is--
AUDIENCE: That
would be the wisdom
of the crowd in that sense.
JULIAN BEINART:
Well, as I can only
judge from Shadrach Woods,
who was a very good architect,
this is absolutely
anti-classical.
The crowd will organize itself
as it goes along and works
and studies.
There will be a
generation of space
which will be more the result of
the participation of the people
than imposed on them.
I'm putting it rather
crudely, the notion that there
is a DNA in all human beings,
according to Chomsky, which
allows a child to
construct complex sentences
without having been
told how to do it,
admittedly with the parents
and society around them
to guide them.
But Chomsky is fairly
well-established
as an authority now.
There's still controversy
around whether the DNA of people
have this capacity
without much learning.
My own position about--
the Free University
has had a bad history.
It's been vandalized.
It's been destroyed.
It's had to be rebuilt. It
never fulfilled the promise
that Woods had for it.
So what we see through
all of these cases,
from Sussex in '61 where the
armature of separated items
in a campus are dismantled
into a system, which
is almost cybernetic in a sense,
free associations of networks
created freely over time
suggesting new relationships.
The trouble with architecture
is that it's not easy.
You just can't take a piece of
paper and stick it on a wall.
The wall has to have bearing.
Acoustics unfortunately
means that the only way
to separate sound is with mass.
The university is the
last place in the world
to flitter around with stud
walls or prefabricated metal
panels.
If we had a prefabricated
metal panel uninsulated,
we wouldn't be able to
teach in this class.
So again, the
Poisson distribution
might guide one into knowing
the frequency of places which
need acoustic separation
versus those that
don't in the same way that
the Loughborough possibility
of making everything possible--
a Poisson distribution would
say that the likelihood
of wet laboratories occurring
in your campus are this.
And, therefore, you should
only spend the money
on a feasible solution, which
requires 70% of your buildings
to have this flexibility.
The Stata building has no
wet laboratories in it.
Therefore, it has nothing--
I mean, if you knew
architecture well enough,
you could look at the Stata
building and our building
and compare them
fundamentally and say,
the one has wet
laboratories, the one
doesn't have any, by looking
at the amount of chimneys
on the roof.
We have every kind of chimney
emanating smoke or gas,
whatever comes from MIT.
The Stata building has nothing.
There's a flat ceiling roof.
It's the only flat
plane in the building.
OK.
I want to look briefly
at two other cases.
The one is the--
by the way, there's a
piece by William Fawcett
in the MIT Planning Journal,
one or two volumes ago,
on flexible life, flexibility.
It's called "Investment in
Flexibility, the Life Cycle
Options Synthesis."
He gives examples
of prediction which
is based on estimates of
outcome and the costing
of the estimates of outcome
and the decision which
is based on the system.
I'd also recommend that you read
something in Kevin Lynch's book
What Time Is This Place?
for an attempt, in the
space-time continuum,
to play around with
the idea of time.
There's a page in which he
goes through a whole number
of possibilities
of changing time.
And he doesn't speculate about
his implications on space.
I'm going to skip a bunch of
stuff and end with the last two
because we won't have time.
I'll deal with this
mainly through the slides.
I can't find the right place.
The two cases are the use
of temporary environment
of a fairly large
scale in cities.
The one is the story of
Paris between 1855 and 1900.
After the success of
the Crystal Palace
Exhibition in 1851
in London, the French
built an exhibition in 1855.
And almost every 11 years
afterwards, 1855, 1867, 1878,
1889, and 1900, it
had an exhibition,
a temporary exhibition, a
major temporary exhibition
in the center of Paris
just north of the Seine
and largely south of the Seine.
I'll go through some of the
material with the slides,
but let me read you a quote
from the French novelist
Jean Giraudoux
about the existence
of a temporary
city in conjunction
with a permanent city.
He's talking about
the citizens of Paris.
"They are delighted
by the thought
of reaching this
cardboard or plaster
city, which is a permanent
stone site of Paris."
What an extraordinary idea,
that part of your city
is rotating at a faster
speed than the other parts.
The Free University of
Berlin has no stone site.
It only has transparency.
Maybe you need a balance between
stone site and cardboard.
He goes on.
"They do not come to see it
disguised and transvestized
Paris."
The exhibitions are
not transvestized
Paris, not changed Paris.
But they are unique.
They are on their own.
"They come attracted
by the temporary union
of an ephemeral city with a
millennial one, the association
of the most eccentric
city with the most
real and tangible one."
It's an extraordinary
idea that you
keep the center of your city
to change at a more rapid rate.
I'll show you slides of 1867
being the first structure
and the demolition.
That takes place within
a period of 11 years.
So every child in the city
is seeing construction
and destruction until 1900.
Of course, the most significant
event takes place in 1889
and considered a
temporary phenomenon.
The Eiffel Tower is
the most permanent
of all phenomena in Paris.
So again, out of this
temporary sea of change,
there are a couple of
items which remain and log
into a system of permanence.
Although the Eiffel
Tower was regarded
as an American structure, easily
taken apart and assembled,
a fabricated structure unlike
the solid neoclassical form
of a Parisian facade.
The Trocadéro, which was on
the other side of the Seine
in the 1878--
the 1889 exhibition,
was demolished.
Although it had a plaster
facade and looked as
if it had been there forever.
So these juxtapositions are
interesting in themselves.
The last and the most permanent
of temporary phenomena
are the Olympic Games.
In 1896, the Olympic
Games was an attempt
to recapitulate one of
Greece's ongoing traditions.
That is the ancient site
of Olympia 776 BC, which
consisted of two components, a
permanent religious component
with priests dealing with flames
and an outdoor camp series
of components, gymnasia,
stadia, palestra, health spa,
and so on dealing with
a cultural attribute
of the body being performed in
competition every four years.
In 1896, [INAUDIBLE] decided
to make some mileage out
of reclaiming this idea.
1900, the Olympic Games
were held in Paris
at the time of the
1900 Exposition.
The Olympic Games was nothing.
It was a joke.
The Exposition was everything.
The swimmers swam the
races in the Seine.
The discus throwers had to throw
the discus in the [INAUDIBLE]
in amongst the trees.
But it was a single
event because you
do two vectors, the
growth of the exhibition
movement from 1855
to 1900 and then
the decline of the
exhibition movement
and then the advent
of the Olympic Games
transplacing the exhibitions.
The Games didn't succeed.
1904, it came to the
United States in St. Louis.
Maybe you don't realize
that the United States
has had the Games four times.
Where?
AUDIENCE: New York,
LA, and Atlanta.
JULIAN BEINART: New York
has never had the Games.
AUDIENCE: It's the--
JULIAN BEINART: Los Angeles has
had it twice, in '32 and '84.
AUDIENCE: Wasn't there a
Winter Games in New York?
JULIAN BEINART: That's
the Winter Olympics.
I'm talking about
the Summer Games.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JULIAN BEINART: Lake
Placid was the Winter Games
where American Hockey
team beat the Russians
and caused enormous
xenophobia in this country.
The Olympic Games really
only took off in '32
in Los Angeles, the
modern games that is.
It's one of the
remarkable events.
It was during the
Depression years.
Only the French were
allowed to drink alcohol.
Oh, it was remarkable.
It made $1 million
profit despite the fact
that not many people
could afford to come.
'36 was the acme of Hitler's
performance in Berlin.
AUDIENCE: How do
you think the films
of Leni Riefenstahl sort of
played a role in the Olympics?
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
Leni Riefenstahl's film--
at the 1988 Games in Seoul, I
was asked to do a presentation.
And I showed the introduction
to Leni Riefenstahl's film
as opposed to the '84
Olympic Games in Los Angeles.
Riefenstahl, in case you
don't know Leni Riefenstahl,
she was the German.
She was the very cryptic and
all over the place German
filmmaker who made Olympia.
She convinced Goebbels
and Hitler to record.
They were very proud of the
fact that Hollywood couldn't
make a film of the '32 Games.
I will show you
some of the still
photographs from the '32 Games.
But Hitler said, we are
going to make a film.
And I could go into some
detail about the film,
but you can still find
Olympia in the 7-Eleven--
not 7-Eleven.
What are the
sophisticated local video
outlets here in Cambridge?
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: It's all
on your computer now.
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
Michael, if you can find it
on your computer, find it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
JULIAN BEINART: Let's
look at these images.
I'm sorry.
I have to show--
I've written about
the Olympic Games.
It's in the reading for today.
I've been to two Olympic Games.
This is the last
meeting of CIAM.
And the arguments had all to
do between the closed aesthetic
of BBPR's building in Milan and
Giancarlos' building in Matera
in the south of Italy.
I haven't got time to go into.
Next.
Some of the projects
of Team 10, this
is Alison and Peter Smithson's
project for the Golden Lane
competition.
You'll see the drawing
indicates an enormous attempt
to create maximized
communication.
Almost every level has people
on it doing something or other.
Here is a building
which takes linear form.
And people are supposed
to socially condense,
to use the Russian term.
It's absolute nonsense.
When I came to America, I
lived in 100 Memorial Drive.
It's a skip-stop
elevator building,
which means that you have
three times the volume going
into the elevator.
I picked up the
newspaper every morning
quite early in the morning
outside the front of my door.
I never, in 10 years, ever saw
another person in the corridor.
Next.
Park Hill Sheffield, one of
the outgrowths of this system.
It's now being
rehabilitated and changed.
You can see, again,
the whole idea
of the pedestrian
sidewalk, which
is a sidewalk elevated in space,
is that people will use it to--
there are just too few people
in a building of this kind,
in most residential buildings,
to generate enough--
as if communicating with
everybody who lives next to you
is a good idea.
I mean, it's a strange notion
in our thinking about urbanism
that we all Greeks
meeting in the area
to discuss our local politics.
We'll come back to
this when talking
about the contemporary
American city.
But there's a mistaken
notion, I think sometimes
argued by Richard
Sennett mistakenly,
that density of
population provides
intercourse between people
in a very spontaneous way.
Yes, you can only get married
to somebody you meet in Philly.
Next.
Another notion by Candilis,
Josic, and Shadrach Woods'
firm, the town of the
extension of Toulouse,
Toulouse-le-Mirail,
the notion of the web.
A web, again, is an
architect geometric form
which is meant to produce
important intersections.
Next.
Pérez de Arce, this
is in your hand.
This is the story of
reurbanizing Chandigarh.
You start off by
building a few things.
Over time, these get added
to and added to and added to
and added to.
And the plan of the central
part of Corbusier changes
over time as the growth
is consistent all along.
So you start with very--
as, I think, Louis Khan said,
I'd like to build a town--
when he was working in Dhaka,
first out of mud and bricks.
And in the end, it
will become a city
of gold, something like that.
Next.
Pérez de Arce's project.
The ultimate goal
would be to exhaust
the center of Chandigarh by
new construction, additions.
That's the Secretariat
building in the distance
and in the case of Louis Khan's
central complex in Dhaka.
De Arce says that, through
a selective additive
transformation, you
can change the city
and build on existing systems
rather than create something
from scratch every
time in a finished way.
Next.
The MIT campus, which
you all know well,
that's a diagram
from Maria's thesis.
The project for the New
University of Bochum
in Germany by Candilis,
Josic, and Woods,
it has no elevations
on the outskirts.
There are just points
of growth and expansion.
They stopped expanding where
the topography curtails
the expansion.
There's a central line
through the system,
but the whole idea is that this
is a space-time configuration
that can change at a speed
which is not yet determined.
Next.
The University of
Zurich competition--
the university is a set of
spaces covered in red and blue
with different rates of change.
Forget about the
one on the right.
That's the University of
Pavia by Giancarlo de Carlo.
Next.
Loughborough-- the 50 foot by
50 foot module fully serviced.
Next-- the French Paris
story and the Olympic games.
The white space is the
transformed white space
of the center of Paris
from 1855 to 1900.
On the right are the various
exposition artifacts.
On the middle at the top
is the first 1855 pavilions
on the Champs-Élysées.
1900, they rebuilt,
as they are today,
and linked to a system across
the Seine on the south.
1867, on the left, is the
perfect around the world form.
1868, it crosses the Seine.
And they build the
[INAUDIBLE] on the left bank--
no, it's on the right
bank in French and so on.
You get the advent of the
Eiffel Tower here, 1889.
You have the contrast between
the apparent temporariness
of this building and the
apparent permanence of this.
1937, this one goes, but
the Eiffel Tower stays.
Next.
1855-- the two buildings
just west of the blue,
the Champs-Élysées.
Continuing here-- the
Champs-Élysées and the two
replacement buildings
for the 1900 Exposition.
I can't reach with my hand.
Next.
In 1867-- 1878, next.
1867, every 11 years you
see this cycle every time
in the construction of
something which is ephemeral.
Then it is-- this is 1867--
being removed.
Next.
Delaunay's painting,
this painting
is a number of features about
the existential condition
of the Eiffel Tower as
a symbol in the city.
And here is an example
of a neoclassical system,
which has much apparent
meaning embedded in it.
But is easily removable
as opposed to that.
You can contrast the
meaning of these two items
in the urban system.
Why is the Eiffel
Tower still there?
It produces more income than any
other public feature in Paris.
Paris is the largest
tourist city in the world.
It spends more money per
capita on cleaning the city
than any other city in
the world, city comment.
Next.
And the final
resolution in 1937--
where the two winners
are the Russian pavilion
and the German pavilion.
Our friend Melnikov's design
for the '37 Exposition
was never built. Next.
The plan of the
original Olympic Games--
the inner core of the
temple of Zeus and Hera.
And outside-- the palestra,
the wrestling, the gymnasium,
the bathhouses, the
guesthouse, the Hippodrome,
and the stadium.
So there's the plan for the
Olympic Games in Munich--
when was Munich, '72?
I think '72.
'68 was Mexico City.
I used to know the dates
all, but I'm sorry.
Next.
1896 in Athens, 1900 in Paris--
next.
1904 in the United States, which
is part of an international--
much like Paris in
1900, 1904 is part
of an international festival.
Here-- bushmen from South
Africa produced to dance.
Bushmen started running
in the marathon,
were chased off the course
by dogs and didn't finish.
The whole system is--
the wonderful
museum of St. Louis,
the art museum the
St. Louis, is still
based on the site of the
original exposition in 1904.
Next.
1932, this is one
of the wonderful set
of still photographs
taken of the games in '32.
Next.
Interesting, here we have,
for the first time, the reuse
of a stadium.
On the left is the vice
president of the United States
in person.
Mr. Garner-- I think
his name was Garner--
opening an exhibition.
In 1984, security is so tight
that the President Ronald
Reagan appears only
electronically,
but the building
remains the same.
One of the
extraordinary things--
well, we'll see it
in the next slide.
Next.
Berlin in '36-- the flame from
the connection to original area
in Greece and arriving in Berlin
with Hitler on the stadium
podium.
Next.
Sorry, I think that's the
wrong slide I believe.
The slide that's supposed
to be on the left
shows the network of the Los
Angeles '32 and '84 stadium.
Transportation wise, it
has worked remarkably well
because it allows distribution
of traffic in every 360 degree
directions.
This is Speer's
project for Hitler
for 400,000 people, which would
eliminate the Olympic Games
configuration and hardly
be able to anybody to see.
Next.
Some of the plans--
this is Seoul.
Most of the stadia are
built on park land.
The wonderful Olympic Village
by Kyu Sung Woo-- at the top.
Next.
I just have cut out most
of the other slides.
This is two aspects
to the American--
a couple aspects of
the Olympic Games.
The Olympic Games are
temporary events in cities.
They've been used,
for cities like Tokyo,
to argue for building a freeway
system or building new housing.
They've been used by countries
like contemporary China,
Tokyo in 1960, Melbourne in
'56, to introduce the city
as an internationally
important place for trade,
for psychological
satisfaction, and so on.
Los Angeles and the
American Olympic Games
at Atlanta and Los
Angeles have argued
that you can reuse
existing infrastructure,
that you can capitalize
on the existing resources
already in the city.
The '84 games builds
no new housing.
The Olympic Village is
based on campus housing
in the University of
Southern California.
The only new facility built in
'84 is the swimming pool paid
for by McDonald's.
So there is not only a
notion of the private sector
playing a role, which--
the IOC, which is a
semi-fascist organization,
corrupt as hell,
controlling the franchise.
The Los Angeles
Games is widespread,
distributed according
to the plan of the town.
The Games in Barcelona are
also very tightly associated
with the major form of
the city, the [INAUDIBLE]..
Next.
Just the Olympic 1928 on
the right, the American team
is housed in a boat, the
ultimate ephemeral item.
This is Cape Town.
I was going to talk
about Cape Town's attempt
to use racial integration as
a social basis for the plan
of the Olympic Games.
They never entered.
Next.
And the project for the
Olympic Games in Boston,
reusing the river and
the university facilities
along the river as the core.
And here is an indication
of how much the Games cost
and the division between the
private and public sector.